let's do it
all right ladies and gentlemen welcome
welcome back to your absolutely
favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
but he's just a sidekick today he's
behind there there he is
you know so we'll talk about that what
y'all thought of that
and i got a lot of stuff to talk about
today tell you about what's going on
with the show
i got locked out of my house american
idol ellen
the golden globes we got all kinds of
stuff on this
jam-packed solo episode so once again
welcome to
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys i'm here to talk about
hellofresh skip trips to the grocery
store and count on hellofresh to make
home cooking easy and fun and affordable
and that's why it's america's number one
meal kit
so welcome back to riffing with griffin
um
yeah big uh i don't know big week let me
just start with you know
i'm trying a new format i have somebody
helping me so it makes it easier for me
so the last episode i was just
introducing you guys to him and i had
him talk a lot there he is
the wigster but for the most part he's
just gonna be doing that he's just he's
there i might ask him some things and
he'll pop in but
he's not my co-host okay so i know all
you guys are like
most of the comments were positive in
terms of like
i don't even know whatever yeah you got
some negative and positive comments
yeah right some constructive criticism
too yeah so we got we listened to your
comments and we got it
but just so you know that that wasn't
like a regular format of the
of the podcast it's still me doing my
thing solo style as you guys know and
then we'll have a guest he'll still be
here even when i have a guest
i i don't have a guest scheduled just
yet but i will have guests coming and
we'll do we'll do it like that
but um anyways you know so thank you uh
wigs for being here again
of course uh so he's there so he'll be
he'll be he'll be there guys he's just
behind the scenes and he'll be there so
so what's been going on um okay so let's
just start
off with a somber sad subject is my the
show
bucktown did not get picked up so
that sucks you know and it really i
really feel for actually the creator of
the show emily wilson i i feel for her
and shout out to her because she fought
for me and betsy
thomas the director and producer and
sarah gilbert you know from she's on the
conners she was also one of the
producers and
and all the people that were a part of
the show it was a really great
experience and it's like it's terrible
because you go through
all of this stuff you know especially
for her imagine you're the creator this
is like your heart project this is like
you know you you you've been you've been
trying to get this made for five years
you know you you've written and rewrites
and did everything you went through the
process you got the pilot picked up
and then you film the pilot and then now
it's just gone
abc owns it they can do whatever they
want they can just shelve it and that's
the end of it and then now what do you
do with all that work and hard work you
put it so i do feel bad for that but
that's the nature of the game you know
there was um they were only gonna pick
up three
pilots apparently this is what i was
told and we were number four
so but anyways even when people tell you
all that stuff like i don't care about
oh because it apparently it tested well
apparently
a lot of things were it was very
positive everybody was like oh this is
great but i'm like i guess it wasn't
because you didn't pick it up so i don't
want to hear none of that [ __ ]
you know i'm just that kind of person
i'm like thank you thank you for
whatever you have to say
powers that be you didn't like to show
if you did you would have picked it up
so it is what it is so that's sad
and i know i went through all this i put
my podcast my gaming people through the
whole process that i was
i was doing too because i was like
talking about the auditions i was
talking about i'm waiting to hear then
we finally heard and now we're back here
again with this and it's like
it's a you know disappointing but
we're gonna start it all over again
because i have a new audition actually
for another
uh television show that's coming that uh
so i'll have a new audition that i'm
working on so
let's hopefully we start this process
again and that's how you do it i had my
day yesterday i was sad about it
and you know i lived with it you know it
was like damn that
you know it's okay to be like that when
you get bad news or something happens
you know people come at you like you
know keep your head up things happen for
a reason i
shut up let me take a day to be sad
you know let me take a day eat some ice
cream watch the notebook you know
equivalent to that and like just deal
with it and now today i'm fine
that's how that's how we do it but
yesterday was a mess i found out about
this uh
the show getting cancelled and then i
got locked out of my place
okay so i have
you know some people like you can't you
have to lock the door so
i have two locks on my door the bottom
was one of those ones that if you don't
close it you can you can get locked out
so i go rachel needs to get to she's
going to work
so i have to move my car so i go before
her i just grab my
key my my the fob whatever it is because
i don't like having the house keys on
that because i don't want my pockets
full
she knows this i walk out i go
downstairs
i move the car she comes down moves her
car as i pull in i think to myself uh oh
i don't have the house key i wonder if
she thought to unlock the door for me
because i do that
for her all the time i just know okay
of course she doesn't so now i'm locked
out i have a nest
a nest doorbell that that both our
phones
are connected to i'm pressing it i'm
sending videos
hey what's going on i'm ringing the
doorbell over and over and over again
by the way at the same time i was
streaming online
i was game streaming i was doing my uh
eric griffin gaming which you can catch
every day eric griffin gaming on twitch
so the stream's going on cause i already
and i'm playing with my boys vinnie
brian
i'm playing with them so i tell them
hold on a second i'll be right back so
of course i don't come right back
and so on their end they hear the
doorbell going eric's at the front door
because i have one of those google
speakers too
so we know that it recognizes you so
it's going eric's at the front door
eric's at the front door so now they're
on the chat
everybody's laughing at me everybody
they're going they're having a good old
time
but then vinnie kind of figures it out
so what he does is he
goes on instagram and dm's rachel
he he dm's her hey i think eric's liked
out of the house
she responds like oh my god whatever
here's my problem
so she don't listen to the notifications
of the nest app but she can get the
instagram dms like what what's that
about you know
like it's so frustrating of course she
comes home
i'm mad okay i even turned my car around
so it could face out so when she pulled
in she could see my face
and see how mad i was that's how petty
mad i was about the whole damn thing
even to the point where i was cleaning
my car out she's gonna listen to this
and she gonna laugh
because i was cleaning my car out then i
heard the gate open and i heard somebody
coming
and i ran so cause i thought it was her
because i wanted to be in the car mad
when she pulled in
[Laughter]
so you know and then she was all like
give me a hug i love you and i just was
like get away from me because i didn't
you know when when you're mad you don't
want to be hugging somebody
you know i don't want to tell you i love
you right now i'm mad now by the way
i didn't blame her i don't blame her i
was just irritated by the situation
especially because she had 81
notifications on her phone from the nest
app
i showed her later and she was like why
didn't he hear and blah blah blah
you know so that was just a nightmare
day yesterday just a complete nightmare
day you know so
that's that so wigs i got some stuff
um i'm uh ready to talk about uh
on on the things and and this is how
he's going to help me because
he got he he i tell him the things i
want to talk about and he went and
looked it up
so there we go oh yeah good you got it
for me ready to go okay so first on the
list uh to talk about it's like ellen
degeneres show got cancelled
she got canceled but you know now for
months people been talking about how
mean she is this is just constant
reports from
her staff from you know ex-staffers i'm
saying and people that have been around
her
all these people are saying all these
things about her constantly like oh
you know and then like it's like a you
know an environment of
you know toxic environment or what one
of those woke words that people like to
use
and so now the the thing got her show
got cancelled but then
she finally got interviewed about it in
this one interview look what it says
ellen
dangerous says negative press cycle
was orchestrated and misogynistic
in her first interview so i think that
she believes that she was like
an attack and you know and i read the
article a little bit and i hear her
talking about like she's saying to her
wife and
and like how sh i think she understands
why people believe this
you know yes right
yeah people definitely uh probably want
to believe it i think i i even wanted to
believe it i mean she
she looks like she could uh she looks
like she could be a monster right
well i mean you can't i mean not
everybody's pretty as you okay
sorry you know so it is what it is you
know like she
no but you could you could like you
could see that uh
you could see it so it was easily
believable yeah so it's like
you know it just feels like it feels
like it's some sort of like
you know i can feel i understand how she
could feel personally attacked
i understand how ellen could sit there
and be like damn like it's just because
because i because i would like to
believe that i well i would bet
if i was a betting man i would say a lot
of these people
that it is a disgruntled employee
situation
and when you have to take everything
like that with a grain of salt people
that used to work for her
they used to work for her so they were
fired for a reason so you would like to
think you know you'd be like well
they're just they're adding to it but
then there's so many people that you go
well
you know is she a nice person you know
is is it all
fake yeah you think maybe there's a
sliver of truth in there right right
right and that's what's wrong with like
putting these kinds of things out in the
press that's what i don't like about
cancer culture and all that kind of
stuff
in the first place that's just what i
don't like about it it's like
there's like some um some real
you know it just it just it doesn't feel
right it doesn't feel
like this is fair to her but at the same
time
i don't know so now we're all we're
never gonna know yeah and it's one of
those things where it's like
what are you gonna do you're not gonna
what she's not gonna go to court so
there's not there's not gonna be a fair
trial of exactly there's no hearing out
what no trial there's no there's not
going to be any this is just a court of
public opinion and
in the public one or or whoever created
this narrative
uh whoever like wanted this to go out
there it's it's been it's done
so now it's just done you know and
there's a lot of stories about it
there's a lot of things about like
you know that there was producers who
were doing the you know inappropriate
behavior and then it's like a lot about
her being mean and all these stories
about her
you know you know but it's like you know
what
like one person's version of like this
person was mean and another person might
be like well this person's just a hard
ass and wanted things a certain way and
that's why she was successful
so it's hard to tell like jordan yeah
exactly it's it's hard to tell what
is what is the
the truth in it it's probably very
nuanced
it's probably there's more to it than
meets the eye
but unfortunately the result right now
is
the public wants results the shark
there's blood in the water
and the sharks wander the sharks are
attacking and that's what happened
and so now ellen is like like like
actually cancelled yeah it's black and
white to the people
yes it's black and white to the people
there's no gray areas so it's actually
cancelled and you know that to me is
unfortunate
you know what i mean all right what else
we got here wigs
we got uh so that was all i want to talk
about another thing that's going on
right now is about the golden globes
the golden globes are going on a hiatus
um apparently this is
this is weird to me because a few years
ago they had the oscars so white
like this was a whole thing it was a
whole thing about
the hollywood is finally addressing
their lack of diversity
and you could now and then the award
shows is where
and by the way and my personal opinion
is at the awards show
is not where you're supposed to be
talking about diversity because it is
what it is
so if you made all white shows well the
reward show
is about well let's recognize about all
these white shows we made
because these are the shows we made so
which ones were the best so to me at the
awards show
is not the time to be talking about
diversity you know but
i understand that this end result is
where you start you go
hey look can we get different people
there so what does that entail
that's talking about producers and
writers and creators it's talking about
what shows get picked up what shows get
made what movies get made who's working
on the movies
all that stuff is like that's more of
the issue that needs to be fixed and i
feel like they're trying
to get to that now so because this has
been such a big deal in the press
because social justice issues and racial
inequality and all this stuff that
people have been talking about now for
the past two years really
now it's coming to a head where the
golden globes they didn't make any
changes
they didn't try they didn't hire any
black people they didn't try anything
they just kept it exactly the way it is
and so now people are now all these
people are like like like tom cruise
apparently gave his golden globe back
it's like oh now
[ __ ] now you want to act like now you
want to act like you're
you know you care you know so you
you know all these people in hollywood
that didn't that were a part of this for
so many years
you know reaping the benefits now that
the public is kind of like
hey maybe maybe it shouldn't be like
this now you want to act like you care
so i mean i guess it's better late than
never but it's a little disingenuous to
me
it's a little bit like come on man you
know how about you start by
you're the producer of your movies you
know you produce like tom cruise
produces his movies
he you know he's he's he he's the boss
so at any point in time he could be like
i want 50 women working for me i want
uh you know let's make sure we have at
least of
everybody that works for me that there's
a that we have a diverse
group of people working here the grips
the staff the you know not just the
actor because because it's not even
about the actors because if you're doing
a medieval
if you're doing a medieval english show
whatever you're doing
i don't want to see leroy there for you
for no [ __ ] reason but to make people
feel good at home no
depending on what you're making will
depend on like the type of actors you
have there so i'm not
i'm not calling for diversity in
everything we make
you know what i mean we can't have a
show about the queen of england all of a
sudden there's a black dude there
like where'd he come from it was it
wouldn't even make any sense
so diversity can be from the top down
from production from creation
all the way up to wherever it is so it's
just it's just
crazy to me that like here we are now
and now this is like an important issue
for everyone you know now all of a
sudden people are like hey
i know i you know it's like i guess
better late than never it's like what do
you want you know i guess
if you're listening to this and you're
just like a person that's like hey
listen i
you might be at home like i'm white i
don't hate anybody
and i'm kind of sick of being blamed for
everything that my ancestors did
can i just watch movies and enjoy myself
can i just watch you know award shows
and be like hey did my favorite movie i
saw
without having to think about oh is this
am i being woke right now sometimes you
just want to like go hey i really
enjoyed that movie
and then you don't you and sometimes you
go i really enjoyed that movie
and you don't take the time to go man
that movie was all white you know if
you're a white person maybe you don't
think like that because you just see a
good or bad movie
you know and i think we all want to get
to that point so
until we're until we feel like things
are normalized
until we feel like things are like right
on track where it's like all right
there's no more
we don't have to worry about racism
anymore we have to worry about prejudice
in hollywood
maybe when we get to that point we'll be
able to be like
ah we'll be able to breathe a sigh of
relief and just watch things and enjoy
him
but until that happens we're still in
the midst of like
you know at any point a cop is something
crazy and we're just reminded once again
oh yeah the cops have
issues with how they deal with
minorities you know you know what i mean
then you gotta then that has to trickle
into everything in our life
and i can understand how that could be
aggravating to some people you know what
i mean like
it's like do you have to be woke 24
hours a day
some people want to be some people
that's your charge some people you've
taken that as like your mantle being
like
i need to make sure at all times people
are aware that there are racial
inequalities there are gender
inequalities that people
are not treating each other nicely if
you want to be one of those people i get
you but i don't necessarily want to be
around someone like that all the time
and sometimes you just want to like can
i just watch an award show and enjoy it
because the award shows themselves have
been ruining it for us
anyway with all the politicizing of
everything it's like
they're on the show making some
political statement it's like hey [ __ ]
just can you just like tell me
which which actor won like i don't need
all this
because who you preaching to you
preaching to the choir because if the
only people watching are just like
liberal type progressive people who like
live on coasts if those are the only
people watching the shows
you're preaching to the choir they
already hate trump
they already think you know that there's
not enough black people and such and
such whatever
they already think that so who are you
talking to right now
all you're doing is alienating the
people that you're trying to change
they're not even listening anymore
imagine if you're at home and you're
just like some
joe schmoe white guy and every time you
turn on an award show they're making you
feel like you did something wrong
were you going to be like this change
the channel you just
right you know i don't know if that's
the way to get the message across
necessarily so i don't know what's going
on with the golden globes i think nbc
cancelled the golden globes which is
like and i don't think
anyone cares
there ain't a [ __ ] outside going
oh my god
they canceled the golden globes what are
we gonna do
nobody cares no one's gonna miss it
because it's not something that people
care about anyway it actually reminds me
of
nfl football in los angeles for the last
25 years we didn't have a team nobody
cared
the biggest media market in the country
nobody cared that we didn't have an nfl
team
because it just we did we didn't it
wasn't something that people in la
gravitated to or because like a lot of
people they come to la
they're from other places so if you're
from chicago you're a chicago bears fan
so you don't care about whatever teams
in l.a because you don't have you're not
you don't live here
but times have changed they got an la
team now so now people are trying to
rally around it and you know
i feel the same way about like with the
golden globes and stuff not enough
people are watching it anyway
no one even cares so yeah i mean this is
right this is so ridiculous because they
have
um it says they have what
19 weeks of reform and it lists like
everything it's just like is this such
bull like what is
all this i know they're trying to like
but but the thing is it's like because
listen
at the same time though i don't want to
i don't want to downplay the importance
of because i do think it's important for
diversity i think it's important to
make people feel included of course you
know i think all that stuff is important
and it's amazing to me that like i feel
like
the people that run the golden globes
said to themselves
is it important you know
are golden globes is that movies is that
[ __ ] it's movie shows it's it's like
it's like a combination of those things
in
in in the entertainment business it's
like you know it's the one that like
encompasses both you know
and it's comedy drama for tv and film
so you know i know the oscars and i know
the emmys yeah the enemies are for tv
the oscars are for they and then the
golden globes is kind of a combination
of both and it kind of sets the tone
a lot of times whoever wins the golden
globe you kind of feel like they're on a
fast track to win the oscars the one
that's supposed to be the most you know
prestigious one
but like with the golden globes you just
go like i feel like they were kind of
like yeah i know all this stuff is going
on
and do people really care and i think
they just got their wake-up call
being like nah people do care
and enough like whiny whiny sort of like
woke people
are leading the charge and listen
i'm not saying don't be woke you know i
think that they're i'm glad they are
doing that
i'm just speaking for me it's like i
don't want to be around that person all
the time
yeah be well where it counts thank you
see
that wiggy's going to come in now with
just little gems like that
he ain't gonna be here all the time guys
remember i said he's you know he's he's
behind the desk
he's there for that he's there to make
the show pretty every now and then you
know
hey guys hope you've been enjoying the
episode but i want to talk to you right
now about helix sleep
helix sleep you know i got the helix
sleep mattress it's great you don't got
to go to the mattress store anymore you
know you don't have to like
you know worry about it's just the right
mattress it's just gonna fit and then it
gets in your place and you don't like it
helix sleep man they offer this great
two-minute sleep quiz and it's kind of
like you know it's like
e-harmony for your body and your
mattress you know if you're a side
sleeper
a light sleeper if you're you know your
your back hurts if you're a heavy set
it matches you and it gives you the best
mattress for you
i got the best mattress i've ever had so
take the two minute sleep quiz
and complete that and it matches to your
body and your sleep preferences i love
that everybody's unique
and helix knows that so they have
several different mattress models to
choose from
so when you go to their website make
sure you check out all the different
mattress models but take that sleep quiz
i'm telling you
you're gonna you're gonna love it i took
the quiz like i said i'm a side sleeper
so i got the best one for that
soft comfortable i love it a lot so if
you're looking for a mattress you take
the quiz you order the mattress and
they'll match it to you
and you don't ever need to go to the
mattress store again just like i said
helix is awesome but
you don't need to take my word for it
helix was awarded the number one overall
mattress pick
2020 and by gq and wired magazine
so must be true right i'm saying it so
that's all you really need to hear about
so
go to helixsleep.com griffin
that's healysleep.com griffin once again
guys
take that quiz and you'll get the best
sleep of your life i can't
guarantee it they have a 10-year
warranty and you get to try it out for
100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but i'm pretty
sure
that you will helix is offering up to
200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners to
helixsleep.com
griffin all right that's healedsleep.com
take that quiz and have the best sleep
of your life
hey guys i want to talk to you about
better help you know i do real world
advice for a grown-ass man
i'm not professional i just like give
some common sense advice i always say if
you have real
issues real problems some things that
you can't overcome
i highly suggest therapy therapy doesn't
solve your problems just helps you
organize your thoughts
figure out patterns help you
maybe see why you're feeling the way you
feel then maybe you can start to change
those feelings
uh and and it's best to be with somebody
who is a professional that recognizes
those patterns and that's what you get
with uh better health
a lot of things are interfering with our
happiness right now you know we got
still we're dealing with the pandemic
we're coming off of that we're trying to
get our lives back
you know our relationships are fractured
and people are doing all kinds of stuff
that they didn't do before we're trying
to get back to that maybe you need a
little push you need a little help
i recommend better help you can start
communicating in under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not a
self-help it's
professional counseling and it's done
securely
online you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule
weekly appointments it's more affordable
than traditional
offline on offline counseling meaning
going to an office
and financial aid is available we deal
with a lot of stuff guys depression
anxiety relationship stuff sleeping lgbt
issues just you name it there's a
professional out there that you can
match with that will help you figure
these things out
all right so i want you to start living
happier
life today as a listener you'll get 10
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor
at betterhelp.com griffin
join over one million people who have
taken charge of their mental health
that's betterhelp.com griffin that's
h e l p help betterhelp.com
griffin for 10 off your first
month start living a better
happier life today take the step
go to betterhelp.com let's get back to
the show
all right so that was uh now let's get
to american idol this little story
but but before we even get to this story
about american idol i want to talk about
american idol first
wigs um i love american idol i've been
watching
and this show is just fantastic this
year
there's like the contestants on this
year's show
you guys i've talked about willie spence
in the past and they got this other girl
man what is the man look up the top
seven uh
see this is what i didn't get to do
before guys remember i would have to
like look on my phone myself because i
was like i'm
a one-man show so no i could be like
tell me to type the last seven
contestants names right now in american
idol
uh uh thing because these people
are so great oh like that's the chick
too like that girl grace her name's
grace
and then in like i she yeah casey bishop
that trick right there too casey bishop
i think she's gonna win
you mark my words because she's 16
she's beautiful and she can sing like an
angel and she sings like rock songs she
sings like
classic songs she sings like pop songs i
think she's tailor made to win
american idol and she sings just great
enough
that even though she doesn't sing say as
heavenly as
willy or even that chick grace she's got
the other parts of the package
that gives her a full a full package of
being an american idol and i'd be
totally fine with whoever won american
idol
now this last episode of american idol
not the one that came out yesterday
according to this episode but the last
week's episode
we got willie arthur gunn's gone
grace um let me see who else
uh hunter that kid's gone he's gone
hunter's gone already
there's only like five left i think yeah
five left it's
grace um willie chase
um this girl i just said
uh whatever the name is against casey
bishop and i think there's one other oh
and that kid caleb he was the other the
fifth kid but
we'll get to him we're going to get to
him so um
so all right so i'm watching the last
and it was coldplay week okay
coldplay week and the dude from coldplay
is there
you know he's he's uh you know he's
mentoring
the they're all singing a coldplay song
you know
and willie who's just this and if you
willy's the one he's saying
rihanna's diamonds it was on youtube
and it went viral you know like it went
viral and it's got like even when he did
it in studio
it's got like 27 million views like
because the kid there he is willie he
can sing i've already talked about how
he got to do something about his weight
and i'm speaking of as a big guy myself
we gotta get
in he because this dude sings so good
i i want him to stay alive you know what
i mean so
he's mentoring with the dude from
coldplay and he sings
the guy's song yellow and i'm telling
you
it is breathtaking like
it's so um you get emotional if you're
into music the way i am if you're into
singing the way i
am the dude is like such a great singer
but here's what it made me think about
this is what i wanted to talk about on
the podcast
about being an artist what is
being an artist because what i realized
is
the dude from coldplay he is not
as good a singer as willy willy's
instrument
is fantastic but to do from
coldplay this [ __ ] know how to
write a song
and that's what makes him an artist and
that's why he is
the dude the coldplay okay because that
song yellow is a beautiful song
and the way willie sung it you go oh man
if this was willie's song
man this would be a hit and then i
realized it ain't his song
and then i went and listened to some of
willy's songs that he hit some of his
original songs
they ain't that good and i go oh
and so when they always talk about the
judges on america they're always talking
about
like who what kind of artist are you
going to be it's also to me about
songwriting it's about like or having
that relationship with whoever you
the songwriter is but that really is the
true art
when you can combine the songwriting
with whatever the talent level is no
matter what level the talent is it has
to have a basic
has to have a basic level of greatness
though you know what i mean but when you
add the talent of being able to write
a really great song combination with a
great instrument that
voice it really creates magic and the
voice don't even have to be
as great as it could be like the guy
from coldplay who can sing great
he's a great singer you know what i mean
but like just do willie sung his song in
a way that i go
damn but i have to remember that ain't
his song
so it's a question i put out to you my
listeners and viewers about like you
know what do you think being an artist
is because that's what i think being an
artist is now after
witnessing this because i really like i
said
just be and you know what and i can
relate it to comedy
being a great performer versus being a
great writer
like for me i know i'm a great performer
i know that i have a boisterous voice i
have a big personality i have a big
demeanor on stage and i
act things out and i can sing and i can
so i'm very much like this animated
figure that is very
entertaining now i have moments where i
have some jokes i'm proud of
and i know that like and i know that
when i hit those moments
those are the moments that my peers come
at to me
with more than anything else loved that
joke
when you get that compliment like oh
that was a great joke
that's the artistry so like some of the
great comics you have right now you know
it's like
chappelle has a combination of all these
things he's such a great order
you know he really his voice
presentation
how he says things that's part of
the instrument but the subject matter
combined with that is where it forms
the artistry and the thing that we
gravitate towards the most
that's the thing that we go oh man
that's what makes that person great
so i really started to think about this
after watching american donald and
seeing the coldplay week and just
realizing
actually how fantastic
coldplay is the guy chris whatever his
name is
as an artist because it just was a
fantastic
uh he's got fantastic songs and to hear
other people sing them
you go oh man this is really you know
you know what i mean so now i also get
why like the people that write the songs
why they make the most money you know
like the publishing rights or whoever
wrote the song
that has the rights to the song that's
the art right there you know that's
really
the foundation of the art so but anyways
so american idol is going so just one
kid that's on american idol his name's
caleb
he's 16. all right and he got in trouble
because so here's the story if you're
looking on youtube it says american auto
finalist caleb kennedy
out after kkk style hood video
surfaces now i saw the video
and i can't tell if this is like
doctored
or not you know like here
like because apparently people have been
adding things to the video
so here's the video right now and he's
like it's a snapchat video and he's
standing sitting next to somebody
and the dude's got like you know a kkk
looking hood on
and then he comes out with this like
well-written apology that i know he
didn't write he's 16 years old even
though the kid writes his own music but
i just don't think that he came out with
this
this worded this wordy ass like you know
uh you know apology that that one of
those kind of apologies that you know
it feels like somebody in the press
wrote it for you so you can make
everybody feel good about what's
happening
so you know you can see you know he's
like hey y'all this is going to be a bit
of a surprise but i'm no longer going to
be on american idol there was a video
that surfaced on the internet and it
displayed actions that were not meant to
be taken in that way
i was younger and did not think about
the actions but that's not an excuse i
want to say sorry to all my fans and
everyone who i've let down
like it's like so it just goes blah blah
on and on and on
now let me just talk about how i feel
about this now again you look at the
video
and they can say whatever they want it
it doesn't look good in terms of like
if you were somebody that's like hey
that looks like clan the kid's a country
singer they're from i'm not even sure
where they're from
but they're from a place that like you
know it's you know country white guys
and when you see a hood like that you go
well this guy be racist right that's
just your where your thoughts go
no matter what they were doing like i
don't like i don't know the context of
why that happened
because i have a whole lot to say about
this because the first thing is
let's just talk about this yo not
everything goes on the internet
like not everything should go on the
internet is what we're learning right
now because what we're learning is
people are digging up your past
and they're taking like chunks of it
little bits of it then they're
they're making your whole character is
based off now
this one moment from an internet post
so if we know people think like that if
we know people are this
this much this stupid and this idiotic
and this
close-minded and just so willing to like
cancel people if we know people feel
like this
we got to start rethinking what we put
on the internet and that sucks too
because it was supposed to be this fun
place that we could share ideas and say
things
and make jokes and all the things that
we've been doing but now these things
are being turned and used against us to
make these virtual signaling [ __ ]
feel good about themselves so here we
are because i have a problem now with
uh first of all the kid is 16.
he's 16 years old okay he ain't his mind
ain't even developed to the point yet
where
he can who whoever he is as a
person has not been decided yet now
let's even go back this video was made
when he was 12
he's 12 years old even if he was around
people who
hate black people and they're racist
they're in the clan he's 12.
you think he has the choice to be like
hey guys i don't want to be around this
you know it's like so if we're really
going to get mad at people
it should be his parents it should be
his guardians
his the people his community the people
that he's around when he was a kid to be
like
yo but i don't know if this was that
we don't we don't know if this if this
was really that they could have been
they could have been capturing somebody
making a bad joke
they could have been capturing like it
was something else i don't know and
that's what they're claiming
it was like a halloween or whatever it
was it's like we don't know what was
going on
but now we're putting the weight of the
racial world
on a 16 year old shoulder saying hey
when you were 12 you should have known
better
hey look at me shut the [ __ ] up that's
how i feel about that
because now for the rest of this poor
kid's life
they're gonna look him up when he's
trying to be a singer because he's gonna
be a singer
okay they're gonna be like oh that's the
kid with the kkk
snapchat video and now now he are you
happy
because that's what i want to ask you
people out there are you happy is that
what you wanted
are you happy with yourself that you
canceled a 12 year old kid
are you happy so the 12 year old kid has
been canceled and what did it do for
racial injustice what did it do nothing
it did nothing
because the real issues that we should
be talking about is like
one putting things on the internet now
uh two
like you know hey parents
you know what i mean like if you're
going to have your kid be in real life
even if you're
even i'm talking even to you racist
people if you're out there watching my
podcast and i don't know why you'd be
watching my podcast if you're racist but
maybe you'd like want to check and see
what the other side's doing you know but
even if you're ra if you're a racist
and you're in your kid's a great singer
at 12 and you know he's a singer singer
12 and he's going to be around
the other part of the world that don't
get your beliefs you got to know that
you're going to put him in an
environment where this stuff is going to
come back to bite him whether you like
it or not
you know whether it's your choice or not
so you know you you know it's like when
in rome
you do with rome right that's what it is
so when in regular society where people
don't hate people for the color of their
skin if you're going to be living with
us
you're going to have to abide by certain
rules and regulations so as a parent
even even you racist parents you got to
be like well my kid's a good singer so
he might have to get a record deal and
then you know
those people we have to appeal be smart
you know what i mean even you should be
smart so i don't blame this kid at all
i i just don't i don't blame this kid
and i know there's people out there
cause i was talking about this on my
stream people like well my kid
knows better i'm like shut up you mean
you think you tell me that
a 12 year old is going to be able to
think about global
issues about race and and all the stuff
that's going on
we would like to we would like to think
that they think about these things and
we're going to put it we're going to
present it to them we're going to talk
to them about it
but to act like it's his fault to act
like
he should somehow be responsible for
the actions of the people around him at
12
is ridiculous right
that's what i have to say about that
wigs big facts
i agree yeah you're 12 year olds getting
cancelled
yes yeah well he's 16 but we really
canceled the 12 year old him exactly
we canceled the 12 year old hymn and
we're making the 16 year old we're
punishing the 16 year old
for 12 year old him where what choice
did he have
you know was it even his video i don't
even know if it was his snapchat
and if he had a snapchat at 12 putting
you know whatever
you know what i'm not gonna harp on it
we're we're done with that
okay we're just
amen
playoffs yeah i think okay i think i
should let's go into the
the nba playoffs so i'm excited about
the nba players because they got this
new stupid playing game
playing tournament that they're doing
right now they got the playing
tournament
not a huge fan of the playing tournament
for and i saw
kenny smith talk about this on tnt
the seventh seed should not be in the
playing tournament
if it was up to me because the seventh
seed they're like seven or eight games
above 500
that's a great season you're having a
great season so you ha
now you're gonna get kicked out of the
playoffs with somebody who don't even
got a
a 500 record because they have this
stupid playing thing
like i get the idea of incentivizing the
players to make them like
because this is the most exciting like a
10th seed all of a sudden is
playing like they have something to play
for so that is good for the fans and i
get the purpose of it
but i don't think that the seven seeds
should be involved in that but this is
what i would do
i would say this if the seventh seed
is 500 or less record then they're in
the playing tournament
but if they're above 500 then they're
excluded from the playing tournament
that's what i think they should do
i think that's what it should be it's
like you know so even if the eighth seed
so that you you want to be out of the
eighth seed
okay so it should be eight nine and ten
you know what i mean
and because i because i don't like the
fact that like the seventh seed
is playing the tenth seed right then
they move on and then the eighth c
is playing the ninth seed and then they
move on so i feel like the seventh seed
is
completely getting messed up by
just a one game do or die
and i think that's messed up so right
now the lakers
because of lebron james injuries and uh
what's his name
anthony davis injuries they are have
themselves right now in the seventh seat
but actually the seventh seat ain't too
bad
because my clippers are in the third
seed
so if if so in the beginning of the
playoffs
one plays eight two play seven three
play six
so you don't i don't know if i were the
lakers if i would wanna play the
clippers in the first round and if i'm
the clippers
i don't know if i wanna play the lakers
in the first round
i don't like that's the western
conference finals that we wanted to see
last year so i don't know uh
you know so i so i think that the lakers
match up better against
phoenix and utah who were the number one
and number two seed
and imagine man imagine you're the utah
you've been busting your ass all year
you have the number one seed and you
might pull the lakers in the first
round lebron james and anthony davis who
are ready after coming off injury you
going to play them in the first round
the first round oh it's
these playoffs are going to be these
players are going to be fantastic i i
think
you know then on the eastern side you
know you still have i talked about this
earlier on in the season on the podcast
about the nets and it looks like they're
getting it together
but i still maintain i haven't seen
james harden do it in the playoffs yet
so we'll see
and kevin durant as good as we all say
he is
when it's just him and kyrie irving they
don't have a good record they don't have
the record that they have when it's just
james harden or james harden and one of
them
so to me it feels like james harden is
the most important player on that team
but they all have not proven that they
can do it without
so and so so kyree was he he did it with
lebron james but before that cleveland
wasn't even making the playoffs
he's not the kind of player that is
going to take a team by himself and make
him great
when he went to boston the chemistry was
all off
when he first went to the nets by
himself the chemistry was all off the
teams were better without him
so now he has that guy again he has two
of those guys you got kevin durant he
got um
james harden okay in terms of james
harden we know he's great
mvp caliber player one of the best
scorers in nba history
he he hasn't proven it in the playoffs
even though they missed 27 or 28
three-pointers in a game seven against
golden state with kevin durant they
could have won the championship that
year against
arguably one of the greatest teams put
together ever right so james harden has
it in him
he just didn't finish the job he hasn't
finished it off in the playoffs
so hopefully this is the year that he
goes you know what i gotta [ __ ]
finish it in the playoffs so this might
be his year
right and then in terms of kevin durant
i'm sorry to me
the jury's still out the jury's still in
on him you know
i know if you say that term right i
never know if you if i'm saying it right
the jury is out or the jury's end
either way when he was with oklahoma
city
he didn't get past lebron james it was
just him and russell westbrook
okay and then when it was him in the
western conference finals against golden
state
two of those final important games he
did not play well he was like
seven for 30 or something like that in
like two of those games that they needed
them to win
they were up 3-1 and choked it away to
golden state
all right and then he leaves that team
and joins golden state
yeah he's gonna be great you know what i
mean so i don't even count those years i
don't count those years to show his
example of his greatness
this is the year that would show if he's
great or not
can he be the the foundation
but hey don't be surprised if they win
the championship
and it's james harden that wins the mvp
of the finals
and again that's going that's going to
show a lot so it's exciting
because then you also have the sixers i
love the sixers i think with doc
i think doc rivers is a great coach and
he's always good in the first three or
four years being with
people because they really listen to him
in his voice he'll lose him later and
he'll get fired
excuse me but for now he's got you let's
see the records yeah he's got them with
the number one
even with brooklyn as great as they've
been playing the
uh philadelphia 76ers got the number one
seat and then you've got the bucks with
giannis they're playing great the
additions that they made to their team
you got the surprise knicks but all
these other teams that don't matter
there's only
four teams to me that really have a
chance to go to the championship and
that's philly
nets bucks and heat and the heat they
are surging right now
and the reason why i say the heat is
because they were in the finals last
year
they got that moxie they got that thing
they want to prove themselves again
they got pat riley running that
organization they got that
what's his name um what's the coach's
name from miami
um eric spoelstra and they got eric
spoelstra
uh as the coach so you know
look out for miami too so i think that's
great and then in the west it can you
know
in the west ultimately i think it's the
lakers the clippers
i mean it could be any of those guys i
think lakers clippers phoenix are the
ones they
really have a legit shot i don't know if
dallas is ready
who knows if porzingis can stay healthy
uh
the rest of these teams like whatever
like san antonio got no shot like
like get them out i wish new orleans
would get their [ __ ] together but you
know we would like to have seen uh zion
be in the playoffs but it's not gonna
happen
you know memphis they got a great young
team i love
john moran that dude is a beast and then
golden state
like golden state got that championship
pedigree but are they ready
so like this is like man you're talking
about lakers
playing golden state in this playing
game like that could be fantastic you
know
steph curry's playing the best of his
career right now people keep saying is
he the best player in the league that's
how great he's playing
people think he's the best player in the
league so you know
that's something to uh that's something
to think about so i am excited for the
mba playoffs so make sure you guys uh
check check that out if you're into the
playoffs you know check that out so
yeah so anyways that's it nba playoffs
so now
so look this is the format of the
podcast look it's me doing my solo stuff
but now we have uh wiggy's corner
so he bringing some stuff to the podcast
right now that uh
yes sir he wanted me to like do some
stuff and so and here we are
i figured 42 minutes in
i figured that let's uh let's get
griffin reacts to some tick tocks
and uh maybe play a geo guesser
or something yeah i got let's do it um
so tick-tock reactions
we need to come up with some kind of
things
okay um
hey guys once again i'm here to talk to
you about hellofresh
hellofresh cuts out stressful meal
planning and grocery store trips
you guys know i cook on instagram and
that's one of the main things that i
love about a place like hello
fresh because if they give you all the
ingredients that you
need for the meal that you're about to
cook and you don't have to stress about
do i have this do i have that
do i have enough of this enough of that
they tell you everything you need it's
easy to follow
and it's fun to do it's a fun cooking
experience try meals ready in 20 minutes
or less
lightening prep recipes and quick
breakfasts and lunches
perfect for your busy schedule so and
you're making your own food and it's
healthier for you
hello fresher's ingredients are sourced
directly from growers and delivered from
the farm to your front door in
under a week contact free of course
hello fresh has been named newsweek's
most trusted meal kit
company of 2021 and over 4
million households served get better
value
hellofresh is 28 cheaper than shopping
at your local grocery store at
72 cheaper than restaurants
meals without sacrificing the quality
and that's the thing i'm going to say
the most all right
uh you know share like when you
have like two or three people in your
place it's just me and rachel
here so like i love to just cook for the
both of us and the portions are great
that's the thing that's great about
those things too you know you're not
over cooking you're not under cooking
you're making a just right
portion and it's just healthier you're
gonna you're gonna feel better you're
gonna lose weight
and that's the the the best part about
these meal plans man
these these you know these meal kits so
i really highly recommend it
go to hellofresh.com slash 12
one two the number one two
hellofresh.com
12 griffin and use code 12 griffin for
12 free meals including free
shipping you guys hear what i said
that's hellofresh.com
griffin 12 griffin and use code 12
griffin for 12 meals including
free shipping
i don't know what else to say about that
go to hellofresh.com
slash 12 griffin let's get back to the
show
all right we're back all right green
screen
they're not green screening but we're
like quick tick tocking i'm tic tac
let me see what's this one about this is
the first one
okay so that's the first one uh well
don't i get to react to that one what's
that
yeah yeah yeah react to that what do you
think about that well i i mean
yeah she got a big-ass booty
oh my god anything we see a white girl
with like a booty like that
it's always that that's that's always a
thing you can ask any white girl like
that
like any time you see a white girl a big
where do you go do a lot of black guys
hit on you and they always do the same
thing they go oh my god all the time
yeah there's always the yeah there's
always the one white guy okay this i
thought was crazy because
it's just it's true like if you look at
this um
you'll like i'll just let you see it but
this video
has no sound apparently every time the
elephant hits the seesaw
people hear a thump so what i need you
to do is turn your volume
all the way
do you like feel it yeah
yeah yeah you feel like a little rumble
yeah okay it's almost like
your mind is telling you exactly it's
supposed to
all right listen wow i thought that was
kind of cool yeah that's that's kind of
freaky
kind of weird kind of weird okay this i
think is it you
no uh but this guy's
this kid's pretty funny how much is that
item five dollars
okay well what i can do for you is
instead of five dollars cash i can offer
you this
mystery box basically the value of this
could be
huge or it may not be huge well i think
you're
underestimating the powers of the
mystery box
no i'm not interested all right well
let's at least see what you missed out
on
all right you could have had you could
have had
1500 cash
could have couldn't i you could have
never underestimate my box
that's right yeah
so i thought that was pretty good oh you
slick piece of [ __ ] see
he you know what he wouldn't have got me
because i would have said yeah what's in
the box
what's in the box what's in the box
what's in the box you know
what what a smug that's that's such a
like he just went to like some dude that
he knew would be like i ain't taking
your box of course
and he got him but that's uh you know
that's what it's like that's like one of
those game shows where it's like let's
make a deal
you know where you go do you want do you
want this 50 cash
or do you want to see what's behind
curtain number four then it's like a you
know
lamb [ __ ] you know what i mean then
you're like damn it i want the 50
bag i can't what am i supposed to do
with lamb [ __ ] but that guy got him
that's a good one what if he does that i
want that guy does that kind of stuff
all the time
yeah he does he does like tons of those
oh little storage so we'll have to start
following him
okay this uh i thought you guys could
vote if i should do if i should try this
or not
the magic removal cream since my last
video got deleted
i'm going to show you how to remove a
tattoo you will need salt
rub the salt in real good
then get cocoa butter roll the cocoa
butter on there good
on the spot where you want tattoo remove
uh
add more salt with with the cocoa butter
rub it on it good
do that for three days after a week
now three weeks of doing this you can
see it's fading away just do that four
times a week
for three weeks as you can see it fade
away free game let's go share this man
free game wow so i wonder i mean
four weeks three times a week
like if you have the patience and the
wherewithal to do that i guess
if it works it works one of my smaller
ones i just don't know like
is that doing anything to the person's
skin is that safe
that can't be good for your skin right
right yeah salt and cocoa butter
i mean i don't know that sounds like
something you put on some ribs or
something like that i don't know if
it sounds like a recipe at a soul food
restaurant yeah
i'm gonna need a factor cap on that one
like yeah wow
someone to test it will you test just
pick one of your like dumb ones
or something yeah see if it works yeah
we'll have to keep track of it yeah i'll
come back and see
what else we got um okay well there's
this youtuber that got
caught up they did a little um
a little uh chris hanson action on this
youtuber guy
he was talking to underage girls and um
and this is actually the game that i'm
about to have you play it's called
geoguessr
and he's playing it and he got put
he got put where they confronted the uh
that guy that youtuber and somehow he uh
guess
why does this alleyway look so familiar
[Music]
this too no
way
this is where edp was confronted i'm
pretty sure it's in bakersfield
so that's uh that's the game you're
gonna play oh well that's terrible so
he so wait so that youtuber
was on the show the chris hanson show or
no they they did like uh uh
they did a uh like a a fake like a use
a youtube version sting operation oh to
catch him and um did it work did they
catch yeah they caught him that's well
that was that video
yeah that video was him being caught at
that location so the location that the
game
sent that guy to was the location that
they caught him
wait wait so it wasn't the guy we were
watching no it was the
it was the guy that was walking so you
confused me yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so it's not that good no it's it's uh
this guy oh it's okay that guy he's a
youtuber yeah that's where he walks
after they catch him because they catch
they have it all on like a little
secret camera oh so it's like it's like
a gotcha
like oh so he's the guy that got him
yeah okay oh gosh you guys
okay okay see now you're making sense
now okay so now wait wait let me let me
tell the viewers
and the listeners because you just
confused the [ __ ] out of everybody right
yeah
so the video we were watching is a video
of a guy
who knew about where another youtube
video person
caught that guy in the video escaping
after being set up
trying to meet with underage girls
exactly boom see how yeah
yeah people uh some of you guys probably
will know about that situation
i don't know if my viewers will but you
know some of them might but um okay
then uh this is the last one and then
we'll play the game um
this is just i just thought this was
tight this guy's killing it all right
let's see
[Laughter]
oh so he created some like return
basketball thing yeah he's just got the
you know the homemade
poop setup
[Music]
oh that's not very sick i thought he was
killing it and where's he from it looks
like he's from some backwater
yeah somewhere out in the south probably
um
but yeah i wanted to know are you good
at are you good at basketball
i used to be when i was a kid because i
know uh where's my
oh where's my picture it's not here but
i have a picture of myself
because i know uh montez was supposed to
be
pretty fire man i almost hurt myself
filming that episode
that little like what was it it was the
the the other cubicle that's what it was
called it was online just an online
version called the other cubicle
and uh we uh i had to like it was about
i i was telling jets that i could dunk
so i went outside and like
they kept lowering the rim till i could
dunk you know and i just i had to do it
like a bunch of times where
afterwards i was done i was like damn i
might have hurt myself you know
your days are done but it was it was fun
that was a fun that was a fun shooting
that
at the right so what's this crazy game
you got me playing here okay so it's
um so if you're listening on the audio
you're gonna have to listen to watch the
video to see like do this
i'll try to describe it as we go so we
can like remember that some people
might know what it is it's called geo
guesser geo guesser and this is like
you're going to show me a place and i
have to guess where i'm at
yeah it puts you anywhere in the world
and
uh you got to guess based off of the
google street view
the google street view i got it all
right geo guessing for google street
view
here we go okay he's setting it up right
now see this is all the fun
these are all the fun things we're doing
with uh
um okay so here we are it doesn't tell
you where we are but uh
so i have to just guess where we are
yeah so there's lots of little things
that you can
alright so it looks like it looks like a
hospital
uh sigma something or other i don't know
what that is sigma aldrich
it looks like it says uh i have no idea
where this is like how would i know
where this is
i don't know i don't know i this this is
wow this this is an impossible game
how can anyone some people are really
good at it oh man
i guess you have to be well traveled in
weird areas
this looks okay there's like a water
tower this looks like i've been verdance
in call of duty um i have no idea where
this is there's like a water tower
there's a fountain
there's like it looks like a hospital it
looks like there's a barn with like you
know a
silo full of grains so that's like like
i don't know i'd have to guess like
sweden or something oh you think it's
something oh
no but look at the cars though you would
know if you could see like you know oh
yeah this does look like some place in
europe
yeah that's right it's got to be europe
right yeah but where
but where in europe who knows all right
well you made a guess let's say denmark
yeah i'd say i'd say somewhere over
there all right where is it
no it doesn't tell you where it is it
doesn't show you the oh it does but
after you got to guess first oh oh i see
oh you have to guess
okay so we're guessing
i'm gonna guess it's just somewhere over
here i don't
i don't know is it sweden
okay not too far see where was it
germany italy austria oh switzerland it
was in switzerland oh wow look at us
okay i get it all right so we were so
you just picked a city
you don't necessarily have to pick like
the exact like it's like you know
you can get as close as you possibly
want people like uh
like on that that edp one the dude that
the one that i showed you he uh
he got it like within a mile somehow oh
[ __ ] knew the exact
location i've been like within like
i don't know like a hundred miles or
something oh wow that's pretty good this
is the next one yeah that's the next one
oh man okay oh that's in the middle of
nowhere
yeah this one's gonna be oh this is like
a it's just like a country road
with like greenery on either side yeah i
want to say missouri
let's see if we can find a oh you can
keep that
or something oh oh yeah that's a guy
this could be florida but i'm i'm i'm
feeling like this is some place in
in in the states yeah it's got it's
gotta be states right and i think that
it
is i'm gonna say missouri let's check i
could see missouri
i could see missouri someplace in
missouri who knows god it's just like a
weird-looking road
let's put yeah i'll put right in here
can't there are no put it closer
yeah more in the rural area
closer to i don't know let's go
hey look look at that
see i'm pretty good at this that's
actually pretty close how far away is
that okay so we were
it was near cedar rapids iowa that's
right
that's where my dad grew up oh wow look
at that look at that
not too bad not too bad okay
cool look at me world traveler
um all right this one looks like oh okay
um this okay this one looks looks like
some projects
you know a little weird writing on the
walls that's russian right
yeah it looks like yeah that's got to be
some place that's that's yeah
yugoslavia look at this parking lot
i know this looks like a weird sort of i
didn't even know google maps went to
places like that
they could just drive around anywhere
you know that's that's if you were like
a spy
you see a the cia dress up as a google
map yeah you dress up as a google maps
driver and that's how you would like
spawn
yeah yeah so i think this is some place
in russia yeah definitely got to be like
austria russia or something yeah it
looks like it looks russian yes you're
right
we saw that riding on the on the on the
side of the building yeah so it's
definitely some russian stuff
um where is russia
yeah we're looking for russia he doesn't
wiggy doesn't know where russia is
oh wow russia is huge that's what she
said
all right so where the [ __ ] in russia
are we
near a city go like near moscow just go
a little bit outside of moscow or
somebody because it looks like it's like
a country rural
yeah place all my russian followers are
gonna be mad
[Laughter]
[ __ ] it we're going near crossing yards
oh and now you're only got seven seconds
and you have to oh okay they make you
pay for it yeah they make that
and that's how they get you they have
this fun game 199 a month though
that's not too bad too bad oh look we
weren't too far oh you were right the
moscow
i said see closer to moscow yeah i
couldn't find moscow
of course you couldn't find it what is
going on in the educational system in
this country there it is right there
what's the next one let's do one more
one more we'll do one more
then we're done with this yeah oh okay
this looks um
i'm gonna say paris no there's palm
trees
so many palm trees no no this is florida
yeah that's what i was getting
in florida this is like near miami
that's where that is yeah it looks super
florida yeah this is miami i'll save
some place near miami
miami beach miami beach just palm trees
and it's like a little dreary yeah yeah
let's put it near miami
boca raton maybe i don't know what's
that right there
oh [ __ ] wow we were way off this is
actually
in morocco
you know that's why i said i was going
to say paris or i was going to say some
place like
that's why my initial thought was europe
well it looks
like somewhere like outside of the u.s
but
florida also kind of looks like that
yeah that kind of had like a
a vacation uh country like like a
vacation resort vibe yeah it had a
vacation shortfire but definitely
all right well we did it uh another
episode of riffing with griffin we're
still working on the format so all the
people that had their complaints about
stuff last week and you know let me know
what you think this week if you or if
you have a suggestion of a game you want
me to play or some
things you want me to do if you go oh
yeah keep looking at youtube twit tick
tock videos maybe you like that you know
we'll see uh what goes on with that yeah
or send us
send them stuff send us stuff to look at
send send stuff to them look at and
comment on i like that idea
real world advice and send stuff for
that too right so now we can start i'm
going to make an
email i'm going to make an email a
special email
and i'll have that for next week because
normally i do it on instagram where i do
the real
i'm going to do that for next week so
next week we'll be doing that and then
we even
we have the ability to like you know
have people
call in and we might set that up or we
have you know i'll have you on the
screen and we can actually do some yip
yapping with uh some real roofing with
griffin fans you know
so we're trying to do some more now i
feel like i feel like i'm more
adventurous because i got my sidekick
here to help me uh
take this podcast to the next level
across the world go across the world
right so listen bitcoin to the moon
griffcoin we need to start griffin yeah
that's what i'm going to do i'm going to
mint you a mint you a coin well that's
well what should it be called maybe do a
contest for what it should be called
and if you have any art or anything like
that and i still accept music you know i
remember
people used to send me so much music in
the past i have a lot of great music
from you guys
artists so if you have some of that
stuff send that um
and remember our game air griffin gaming
make sure to check that out
make sure you send me uh you know fill
out your comments and subscribe
and like and make sure you you know hit
the like button guys
hit the subscribe button and keep coming
back and
i hope you enjoyed this episode and i
will see you
next
[Music]
you